Mitsubishi's projeto was designed to be
a workhorse a sport utility vehicle with
utility writ large it boasts a good
three and a half tons towing capacity in
Spanish Pacheco or Pajero has a rather
off-color meaning so in most of Latin
America and Spain is called the Montero
in the United Kingdom it's known as the
Shogun whatever the name it's big
powerful robust and very straightforward
[Music]
contest irani left's taxis that
Mitsubishi is keeping its
all-wheel-drive classic up to date with
cautious modifications the car is well
known as a decent off-roader
and spacious 7 seater ronnie has a look
at that third row of seats behind the
large tailgate he expects to find plenty
of trunk space but it takes him a bit of
work to fold the third row of seats up
[Music]
he anchors the seats and pulls the lever
folds up the seats and puts the
headrests in place now he's going to
find out how it feels to sit back there
Ronnie folds a seat in the second row
down to climb in back and get an idea of
the space he doesn't seem to have any
room for his knees at all he has to
wedge them in tight against the seats in
front he's got enough Headroom
but the third row of seats wouldn't be
all that comfortable on long trips the
SUV weighs about 2.4 tonnes
it's powered by a hefty 4-cylinder
turbocharged diesel with 3.2 litres of
displacement it puts out 140 kilowatts
and achieves a maximum torque of 441
Newton metres it can reach a top speed
of 180 kilometers per hour
[Music]
Rahmi notices the five-speed Automatic
transmission shifts smoothly and even
helps save fuel the carmaker rates
average consumption at 9.3 liters per
100 kilometers but our test drive
averaged 1 or 2 liters more brawny says
Mitsubishi emphasizes how much it's been
able to reduce vibration but the throaty
sound of the turbocharged diesel gets
much louder inside every time he steps
on the gas the boxy off-roader has
little to nothing to do with lifestyle
statements the fourth-generation built
since 2007 still looks like it just came
off the farm and has no time for
joyriding
[Music]
the interior features full-grain leather
upholstery and wood trim on the steering
wheel and center console with a 6.1 inch
touchscreen that together with the
Rockford sound system gives the car a
touch of 1990s charm
[Music]
even the multifunction display has
something of a classic look to Ronnie a
Mitsubishi Pajero in town comes across
like a farmer at a ballet but in the
country it's just the right size and in
fact 91 percent of its buyers order it
with a trailer hitch